fear is my friend uh-huh i love fear
fear fear allows me to reach my highest
potential
and the fear of failing is an illusion
yeah fear is an illusion but we have to
have desire we have to have something
that pushes us fear pushes us
we don't understand that living prepares
us for death our life it prepares us for
death
you know even if we die young it
prepares us
so just the fact that we're losing guys
like colby lose we just move them people
in our families people dying surrounds
us all every day so we prepare for it
we understand that but we avoid it do
you have any methods
for getting through fear excuse me do
you have any methods like how do you how
do you get through fear what
if somebody says yes i'm afraid right
now and uh
whether it's preparing for a fight or a
football game or a business meeting or
i'm going to ask this girl out like how
do you how do you get through that fear
what what
listen this is the thing right whatever
we do in the sports life and
when you don't when that when you don't
have that feeling no more
it's over and you don't get that fear
number is over
yeah meaning that it's gotta
that that's that's that's the
measurement stick that that's that's how
you know you're going in the right
direction keeps us alive
yeah listen you think a deer a deer
comes through a lake he feels the
intention is a lion
in the tree so normally he had jumped 50
feet but with that fear he jumped 40
feet
yeah you know it's the flight of its
survival
our fear makes us think things that
don't even exist
our biggest fear never happened whatever
we're afraid of in life our biggest fear
never happens
we go to our grave saying well this
shit's never happened i was waiting for
this it never came
you know it's just um it motivates us
that's here that's the direction that
you need to go well i don't fear we're
nothing i know we get hit by cars every
[ __ ] day
we just walk out we oblivious fear keeps
us conscious of our existence
it keeps us um conscious of knowing that
we're mortal
so before each fight were you afraid
listen right and i'm a guy i'm conscious
i understand the process of fear
because i was 13 for i understand the
process i was taught
and i just i was scared of crying before
but i don't know why i'm gonna try to
get my ass here i'm crying because i'm
gonna lose the same people not gonna
love me no more i'm not gonna be nothing
i'm gonna go back to brownsville nobody
else
nothing i'm a failure in life i'm
nothing i'm a [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] and then i'm a [ __ ] then as
soon as they say it's time to go i turn
into a monster
how does that happen
how do you think it happens i don't
i feel like for me i had to do the same
thing
i used to cry i used to be so nervous i
just tell myself i'm not playing
football
anymore when i first started even after
i went through my failure of pop warner
when i got to freshman football
sophomore year football i was like i
don't want to do this anymore i'm so
scared right now the butterflies
and then we go out there after that
first hit it's like
okay i'm in the game now and i loved it
while i was going on
and then after the game would go back to
that like little bit of fear
what did you know about projecting
you mean getting out in front of it
seeing it happen before it happens or
throwing it out there you know listen
check this out another way on your cast
right up
where i came from everybody abused me
beat my ass kick my whatever they wanted
to me
and now i'm the baddest [ __ ] on the
planet
well so what they say yeah how does that
happen
i'm a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] and i'm the
baddest they're gonna plant on a stage
and telling everybody
come on i want to fight you [ __ ] i'm
doing everything i'm just i brought my
[ __ ]
pain with me i kept that's what i don't
do no more i don't bring my [ __ ] pain
with me
i [ __ ] my career because i brought my
[ __ ] pain in the past but
it enhanced me to do so much [ __ ]
incredible [ __ ]
but it [ __ ] me up yeah